hi I'm Ned and I'm married this week
we're doing a makeover challenge
what do boyfriends want their
girlfriends to wear for date night
let's find out I ship it fashion is so
important because your outfit speaks
before you do each of the boyfriends
secretly submitted costume ideas to
Lindsay and now we're gonna surprise
them with their choices let's bring out
the couple's the PS style is great I
love her style pretty trendy and
mysterious buzzword buzzword bug like to
see her go a little elegant a little
old-school that Audrey Hepburn Audrey
Hepburn Audrey Hepburn I definitely have
a lot of cheap clothes I'd like to go
shopping a lot so I don't like to spend
a lot of money I think that she'll
really embrace it I love that you really
went there because she's going to wow
you in a different way I tend to wear
baggy things like this that she likes to
call maternity clothing I call it that
once and it was a joke that we both
laughed at sorry it's done it's not what
Steve picks out for me when we ever go
shopping together the shortest skirt
possible and the really tight white
shirt Wow I feel like I'm being put into
a box I'm excited to see just something
different how they tighter-fitting are
like classic modern a little bit more
preppy a little more preppy yeah yeah
your family isn't a stripper no no hey
look sweaty a little nervous because
Steve gravitates towards things that are
a little shorter showing off a lot of
skin she's not excited I'm excited I
just think he picked out a very
scandalous outfit Wow getting right to
our style is really laid-back like a
jeans and like a shirt I feel like the
true essence of like style is not really
caring definitely more the fashion one
of our relationship for sure she knows
how much like I love just like Kanye's
style I think it'd be great to make her
dress like you know a pregnant elegant
you know like Kim Kardashian was rockin
that was a cool style like there was a
lot of haters but you know it's a
pregnant woman to be quite honest you
should be able to wear and do whatever
the [ __ ] you want yeah because you are
creating the biggest me
full in light you guys ready to get
started why don't we go try some stuff
on
you ready yeah what do you think you
look like hopefully like Audrey Hepburn
but she's a very petite woman so we'll
see
yeah I'm looking forward to seeing it
let me in they look super fancy good
open your eyes
whoa
I look like okay very adult you do yeah
you look very streamlined sexy very
stylish I don't know like I feel like a
hot mama yeah yeah open your eyes
oh this is cute it's definitely not
something I would pick out for myself
but I think it's really cute I could
definitely see myself wearing it it's
nothing like what I thought Steve would
pick out thank god yourself out oh wow
you liking it I look like Anne Hathaway
from Princess Diaries I think hello is
it me
oh damn I feel great I think he's gonna
be into this I feel like kind of bashful
like I feel really dressed up are you
excited to me yeah I am I'm ready to see
this I've been waiting let's do it
open your eyes oh look at that look
beautiful
thanks pin I love it you can open your
eyes okay oh wow you all dressed in the
only thing in LT oh yeah great good
you're gonna see surprised you like it
yeah all right yeah
haha great thank you like super it's
like a choice oh I wasn't expecting this
here I guess she is wearing a tiara in
breakfasty - wait what do you mean you
weren't expecting to see our you wrote
that in the evite yeah it would be great
cold out I had your face no it could be
like a [ __ ] but I'd be okay with this
like a Blair Waldorf I'll take that it
is very different the makeups very
different but I think what were you
expecting nothing it's like it's super
like sexy - be careful - same thing
being dangerous
we're an amazing place fully dressed up
so Tyler's choking on his icecream
but he's stylish and who cares good